y'en a qui vont se faire virer oh non
c'est ma soeur vous avez prévu une fête
de noël ce soir annonce n'est pas une
fête de noël c'est un petit cocktail
multiconfessionnelle plus fédérateur
dans quel que soit son nom ça n'aura pas
tous d'accord c'est d'annuler et du coup
tu crois peut-être que je t'ai pas vu ok
on fera comme tu voudras ses filiales
est en train de couler je vais la ferme
et tu veux nous laisser un peu de temps
pour faire nos preuves
et bien si par miracle vous signer le
contrat de 14 millions de dollars avec
walter davis tous les employés restent
ok tu verras tu auras l'air bête
du coup on aura enfin un truc en commun
je la déteste électrochoc
les amis et si on lui faisait vivre la
meilleure soirée de sa vie à notre fête
de noël ce soir ainsi tout le monde
gardera son job c'est pas si bête que ça
walter vous aimez défaite avant oui vous
avez vu ça ce soir venez vous l'a collé
présence obligatoire france est assurée
c'est mon anniversaire
là je vois qu'on est à fond dans son
rôle halim les bouger
recto la cheminée la meilleure fête du
millénaire hashtag open bar tu envoies
sahara qui a touché cagots du pdg d'oséo
texte s'il vous plaît conduisait je
viens juste de déposer genre quatre
personnes à leur petite tête de soir
elles m'ont mis que trois étoiles cette
pente de [ __ ] qu'est ce que vous avez
dit j'ai dit que c'était une bande de
pétasses astuces ce soir les décisions
que vous allez prendre risquent de boue
suis pour le restant de votre vie
professionnelle
arrête toi ou je te tire une balle dans
le proc j'aime la mer
hécatombe
d'accord cette hausse est est ce que
vous lui avez fait jaser en s'amputant
je crois qu'il s'est totalement foiré
oh
les a trouvés ou mieux vaut ne pas
savoir y at il autre chose à voir
en fait oui voici un exemple de plateau
de fromages dans d'autres petites fêtes
de ce soir je vous avais une fête de
noël ce soit c'est pas une fête de noël
c'est une soirée sans la moindre
connotation religieuse plutôt fédérateur
ce soir pas de fête
oui je te suis là dessus il n'y aura pas
de fête ce soir au sens propre de soir
car ce sera 17 heures c'est pas un gros
truc tu sais juste une petite fiesta
mais pas la peine quotidien et crois moi
ça risque d'être chiant ça ne risque pas
d'être chiant parce que c'est annulé
quoi dans toutes les succursales les
fêtes ont été annulés ok c'est annulé et
clay je ne plaisante pas mais moi non
plus les enfants
sachez que la petite soirée d'annuler
oui je suis en train de regarder du
conte je te vois tu chantais à la
crémière péteuse
[Musique]
c'est formidable
tellement fière de toi tu peux me passer
papa au téléphone une seconde ellison
des prêts t'es vraiment un gros temps
fort et si j'apprends encore que ton
espèce de [ __ ] à trimballer mes gosses
sur sa moto de pouffiasses jeta me
antilles comme dans call girl ou alors
j'y vais merci beaucoup
[Musique]